The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high-quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Let's get
right into it.
So last day, we started looking
at Roentgen again and
the generation of x-rays, which
we saw occurred when we
operate the gas discharge tube
at high voltage and low
pressure and this is the
image that we saw
of his wife's hand.
Birth of medical radiography.
And we started looking at the
origin of x-rays and we
started looking at the energy
level diagram of the target
anode in the gas discharge tube
and this is the energy
level diagram of the target.
So the ballistic electron--
I'm calling it incident--
this is the electron that's
making its journey across the
x-ray generating tube.
It left the cathode and it's
moving across and crashing
into the anode.
So this is the target
or the anode.
So let's label it as such.
So we're looking at one of these
mixed metaphors, where
we've got both a Cartesian image
here of the electron and
we've got an energy image.
So this is the target or it's
the anode and it's charged
positively and so the
electrons are
crashing into it.
And we reason that what would
happen is, if the electrons,
the ballistic electrons, had
high enough energy, they could
actually dislodge 1s electrons
and when they do so, they make
the conditions for a cascade.
So you can see electrons falling
from n equals 2 to n
equals 1 and when they do
so, they emit radiation.
They emit photons and these
photons are called K alpha.
K because the final shell
number was n equals 1.
And remember, the
spectroscopists
prefer to use letters.
So when the electron ends at n
equals 1, that's n final, we
call it a K photon.
And furthermore, the subscript
alpha means that the delta,
the n initial to n final
is only one.
So when you go from 2 to
1, you get the K alpha.
And less likely but still
possible is the transition
from 3 down to 1.
So it's still called a K photon
because the electron
that generated the photon ended
in the K shell, but it
traveled from a delta n
of 2, went from 3 to 1
so that's a K beta.
Over here, obviously if we have
enough energy to kick out
K shell electrons, we have
enough energy to kick out L
shell electrons.
And so if we lose an L shell
electron and we have a
cascade, then anything that
ends in n equals 2 will be
called an L photon.
If it comes from 3 to 2,
that's a delta of 1.
That's the L alpha.
It it falls 4 to 2, that's
a delta of 2.
That's the L beta.
And so you can see you
get a set of lines.
And that set of lines
looks like this.
We can plot a spectrum of this
entire set of lines, which
will be characteristic of the
identity of the target.
And I think I showed you last
day that it's going to look
like this, where we will plot
intensity and the intensity on
a spectrum is related to the
frequency of occurrence and on
the abscissa, we're going to
have some kind of energy
coordinate.
We can put lambda increasing
from left to right, which
means energy increases
from right to left.
And we saw that we have this
family of lines where we have
a discrete line at the energy
of K alpha and a second line
at the energy associated with K
beta and K beta has a higher
energy, therefore, a lower
wavelength, and the relative
heights related to the relative
frequency, again, not
to scale, but still the general
relationship is correct.
The likelihood of falling from
2 to 1 is higher than falling
from 3 to 1 and so you'd expect
to have the intensity
of the K alpha line greater than
the intensity of the K
beta line and the L lines have
to be of lower energy because
transitions 3 to 2 are less
energy than 2 to 1 so we
expect those lines to be out
here and again, a relative
frequency where the L alpha has
a slightly lower energy
and L beta has a slightly lower
frequency of a current.
So that's the spectrum and this
we call characteristic.
Characteristic of what?
Of the identity of the
anode or the target.
This is generating the x-rays.
So if I want x-rays of this
value of wavelength, I choose
the target appropriately.
That's why we have the
relationship here.
And then the other
thing is that--
it's obvious, but I just
want to make sure that
we put it up here--
it's quantized because we're
looking at the photons coming
at discrete values of energy.
So that's what we
speculated on.
Are there any data?
The answer is yes and the data
come from a young man by the
name of Henry Moseley.
He was doing his PhD
up in Manchester.
He was is working
for Rutherford.
Rutherford was his PhD thesis
supervisor and 1913, 1914, he
was making systematic
measurements.
He was conducting a systematic
study of the characteristic
spectra of no fewer than
38 elements of
the Periodic Table.
And what did we learn from
his measurements?
Learned from his measurements
that there's was a pattern
here and here's what the pattern
is that Moseley found.
He found that if he took
the value of--
I'm going to just
take one line.
If he took all of the K alpha
lines from 1K alpha per
element and he plotted the value
of the wave number of a
particular line, he found that
the value of the wave number
of a particular line scaled
with the identity of the
element by the square of
the proton number.
So, for example, we would
have, say here we
started with aluminum.
So aluminum proton numbers
13 so 13 squared.
And he went all the
way up to gold.
Didn't do all of them but
he did, as I say, 38
from one to the other.
And these are discrete values.
You have different elements here
and gold is up here and
he found that he could take the
set of data for, say, all
the K alphas and they
lie on a line--
new bar--
as if proportional to the square
of the proton number
and he did the same
with other lines--
say, L alpha and so on--
found that they lie on a line.
So what does all of this mean?
Well, let's take a look.
Here's the image of the paper.
High-frequency spectra
elements.
Henry Moseley, Master's degree,
so he's working on his
PhD, and the data were
taken as follows in
photographic plates.
And so by trigonometry, you
can figure out what the
wavelength would be of the line
that would go to this
degree of distortion, et
cetera, et cetera.
It's a beautiful set of lines.
Look at how these
date are posed.
So there's calcium.
Scandium is frightfully
expensive so you
don't see it here.
Then there's titanium, vanadium,
chromium, manganese,
and as you change the element,
the wave number, the
wavelength, the energy of all
of these lines changes
systematically in accordance
with the square of the proton
number, and we got over
here to copper.
Next one is zinc. Zinc melts at
420 degrees Celsius, which
is relatively low melting.
And under the bombardment
of electrons--
the bombardment of zinc would
cause it to melt and so rather
than work with zinc, he instead
worked with brass
because brass is an alloy
of copper and zinc--
and look carefully.
You can see that brass has
four lines, two lines
identical to the lines of copper
and these two new lines
are the lines associated with
zinc. And I mentioned last day
that you could actually
deconvolve the complex spectra
and identify the constituent
elements.
So this was really fantastic,
really fantastic.
Si what did we learn
from all of this?
What did we learn
by these data?
well, first of all, corrected
Mendeleyev What
do I mean by that?
Not here to say bad things
about Mendeleyev, but
Mendeleyev had told us that
periodicity is a function of
the atomic mass.
That's what Mendeleyev said.
Periodicity is a function
of atomic mass.
And now Moseley says no.
Moseley says that
periodicity is a
function of proton number.
And you can see here--
I wanted to show you the--
this is an image taken
from his paper.
He worked for Rutherford.
These people were brilliant
experimentalists and
so here he's got--
the cathode is up
here at the top.
You see cathode of x-ray tube
and the feed through and so
on, so the anode is down here
and it's connected and so on,
and rather than take the x-ray
tube apart in order to change
the target, he went to the
toy store and he bought--
this is the train from the toy
store and he's got different
elements seated next to each
other on the flat car of the
train and he's got feedthroughs
with silk fishing
line so that after he's done
the experiment with one
element, he can pull the train
car over and change the anode
without having to take
the apparatus apart.
These guys were very, very
good experimentalists.
So here's from his paper.
The author intends first to make
a general survey of the
principal types of
high-frequency radiation and
then to examine the spectra of
a few elements in greater
detail with greater accuracy.
The results already obtained
show that such data have an
important bearing on the
question of the internal
structure of the atom and
strongly support the views of
Rutherford and Bohr.
It's 1913.
Remember, that's when
Bohr paper came out.
All these people were working
in the lab at the same time,
supporting each other.
You see, this doesn't make any
sense with a Plum Pudding
Model, does it?
See, he continues: "We have here
a proof that there isn't
the atom of fundamental
quantity, which increases by
regular steps as we pass from
one element to the next.
This quantity can only be the
charge on the central positive
nucleus on the existence of
which we already have definite
proof."
See, not only-- remember, the
Plum Pudding Model has this
big blob of positive
charge nests.
There are no protons.
In the nuclear model, we have
a nucleus that has positive
charge and he's saying, I know
there's positive charge, and
it increases as you go from
one element to the next.
We are therefore led by
experiment to view that N-- we
use the letter Z today.
He's using capital N.
N is the same as the number of
the place occupied by the
element in the periodic
system.
This atomic number-- for the
first time, the term atomic
number is used.
That's why I was being coy here
and I kept saying proton
number, because that's
the way they knew it.
Now he's say, this is
the social security
number of the element.
Proton number is then for
hydrogen 1, helium 2, lithium
3, calcium 20, zinc
30, et cetera.
We can confidently predict--
look at-- this is the
masters student and
he's going on a limb.
He says: "We can confidently
predict that in the few cases
in which the order of the atomic
weights A clashes with
the chemical order of the
periodic system, the chemical
properties are governed by N,
while A itself is probably a
complicated function
of N." He's right.
You look at the Periodic
Table.
You say, yeah, yeah, they just
go in descending mass or
ascending proton number.
Look carefully.
Potassium has a lower
mass than argon.
And nobody's to--
well, if you were Mendeleyev,
you'd say, go back
and measure it again.
Well, they have measured it.
These are the accurate values
and no one's going to put
potassium underneath neon, but
it comes next in the order of
ascending atomic mass.
Cobalt and nickel--
nickel actually
weighs less than cobalt.
But they're transition elements
so who cares if you
get those two mixed up?
You find them in stainless
steel.
It doesn't matter.
This is a good one.
Iodine is lower mass
than tellurium.
Iodine is a halogen.
It belongs under fluorine,
chlorine and bromine.
You're not going
to put it under
oxygen, sulfur, selenium.
But look, there's the data.
And then last one that Moseley
couldn't have known about is
transuranic synthetic element,
but that's just the fourth
case in the periodic table.
So that gets you the last wedge
in Trivial Pursuit.
What are the four pairs
of elements
that are out of sequence?
OK.
So now we can say that proton
number is the atomic number.
It's the identity.
So that comes out of Moseley,
comes out of his work.
The second thing that he did as
a result of his study of 38
elements is he figured out
what to do with the
lanthanides.
Remember our friends,
the lanthanides.
Place the lanthanides
correctly in
the Periodic Table.
Many of the lanthanides have
a valence 3 so people were
struggling.
They were putting them
underneath aluminum.
They didn't know what
to do with them.
He placed the lanthanides
correctly in
the Periodic Table.
And it's not as though
these were brand new.
Lanthanum itself had been first
isolated in 1839, and
all through the 1800s, they
were picking them up and
finally, lutetium was the
last one discovered,
categorized in 1907.
But people didn't know what to
do with them and remember,
they were obsessed with atomic
mass measurements.
So I'm going to give you this.
I'll give you this piece
of information.
There's the atomic mass of
lanthanum, and the atomic mass
of lutetium is 174.97.
So what?
I don't know what to do
with that information.
That doesn't help me at all.
But now comes Moseley and he
says, we're not talking about
atomic mass.
We're talking about
atomic number.
So now I tell you this
atomic number is 57.
So where do you put it?
Duh, you put it right
next to barium.
There's no debate.
And furthermore, this
one is 71--
atomic number.
Well, if this is 71 and
this is 57, I can
tell you with impunity--
how many lanthanides
are there?
There's 14 of them from
here to there.
OK.
14 elements, which makes sense
because in s we've got one
orbital, in p we've got three
orbitals, and d we've got 5
orbitals and these are f
and there's 7 orbitals.
7 times 2 is 14.
Everything makes sense.
And the last thing that's a
corollary to the item two--
we were able to give
uranium its proper
atomic number is 92.
So now I ask you, how many
elements are there up to
uranium starting
with hydrogen?
92.
All of this comes as the
result of Moseley's
experiments.
But it's not over yet because he
worked for Rutherford, and
Rutherford pushed his
people really hard.
He wasn't abusive, but he
brought out the best in them.
So who else was in
the building?
Bohr, and what were
they doing?
They were doing theory and so
he said, well, that's nice,
but he says, I want those things
fit to an equation.
So Moseley said, all right.
I'm going to use--
there's already an equation in
the building for a new bar.
It's the Rydberg equation.
So I'm going to use a
Rydberg-like equation.
So this is what he does.
This is Moseley's fit.
He goes the wave number of
whatever the line is-- whether
it's K alpha, L alpha, what have
you-- is going to go as
the product of the Rydberg
constant--
1/NF squared minus
1/NI squared.
So far that's just the
Rydberg equation.
But now comes Moseley's
contribution.
We're going to put z squared,
but one more piece.
Notice the way I've
drawn those lines.
They don't go through
the origin, do they?
There's an offset.
So he said, let's allow
for the offset--
z minus sigma quantity square.
And this is known as
Moseley's Law.
And you've got values
for sigma.
sigma for K alpha equals 1 and
for L alpha equals 7.4.
So now I can--
with impunity, you give
me the wavelength.
I can get the wave number-- it's
1 over the wavelength and
I can plug into this equation
and identify the element or
turn it around if I want to get
wavelength radiation of,
say, 1.25 angstroms, I can plug
into this equation and
come up with the z, which will
tell me what the target
element choice should be.
So let's go and plug this in
because we're only going to
look at these two.
So we can say that the wave
number for K alpha--
it's always going to be 1/2
squared minus 1/1 squared,
which is always going
to come up 3/4.
So it's 3/4 times Rydberg
z minus 1 squared.
So this is for the 2:1 or, if
you like, L to K transition
and then the other one
of interest here
is nu bar of L alpha.
nu bar of L alpha's going to
be 1/3 squared minus 1/2
squared, which becomes 536 times
the Rydberg constant z
minus 7.4 squared and this
is for the transition 3:2
or KLM, M to L.
OK.
So there it is.
And now, what's the significance
of all of this?
I try to give a physical
significance of this sigma,
which is known as the
screening factor.
We're going to call sigma here
the screening factor.
You'll see why in a second.
Why are we calling it the
screening factor?
So let's consider what's
happening in the case of the K
alpha lines.
Let's look at K alpha
generation.
So not to scale.
Let's draw--
here's the nucleus with all of
its z positive charges and
then I'm going to draw the
K shell, and its got two
electrons in it, and I'm going
to show there's a hole here.
Because without this
hole, there's no
reason for the cascade.
And then I'm going to draw the
L shell and it's got-- what?
There's 2 from the s, 2s,
and then 6 from the 2p.
At most. I know this is
a terrible model.
It violates all kinds of things,
but it's as complex as
it needs to be for the
explanation I'm about to give
and I don't want to load you
down with a whole bunch of
extraneous information.
So consider the electrons
in the L shell.
They see the electron vacancy
in the K shell and they're
going to fall down.
What's the Coulombic
pull of the nucleus
on the L shell electrons?
Can you see that it's not z
plus, but at z plus screened
by 1 minus.
So the nuclear charge
is mediated--
in other words, it's reduced by
1 thanks to the presence of
the one negative charge here.
So these electrons in L shell
feel z less 1 and hence, we
get z minus 1 as screening
factor.
It's plausible.
It's at least physically
consistent.
Now let's look at
the next one.
That's the transition
from M to L.
OK.
So we get to M.
We've got 18 electrons, up to
maximum of 18, and if they're
going to fall down to n equals
2, there needs to be at least
one vacancy here.
So now let's use
the same logic.
So an electron in the m shell
sees the positive charge of
the nucleus mediated by the
electrons between the shell n
equals 3 and the nucleus.
Now, I don't know how many
electrons there are.
What's the extreme case here?
Two, four, six, seven,
maybe eight, nine.
Because this would still give me
the conditions to generate
the transition 3 to 2.
I need a vacancy in two.
I don't need a vacancy in one.
So this is the maximum.
so that would be two, four,
six, eight, nine.
So it could be z minus nine, but
that would mean that all
of these electrons are on the
same side and I don't have any
vacancies lower.
I only have one vacancy here.
That's an extreme.
It's not observed.
And the other extreme is, we
blow away all the electrons.
So somewhere in between 9 and
0, it turns out it's 7.4.
I can't predict that it's 7.4,
but 7.4 makes sense.
If the number were greater than
9, I would be distressed.
So it makes sense,
rationalizes.
OK.
And by the way, if you use this
formula, Moseley's Law--
let's bring that back down.
Remember, I told you I can still
wake up in the middle of
the night and quote you the
wavelength of copper K alpha
radiation of five significant
figures.
I had it drilled into me
in my junior year.
It's 1.5418 angstroms.
That's the lambda.
So you can use this formula for
new bar and you know that
new bar is equal to
1 over lambda.
So I can use Moseley's Law.
But true value, lambda--
I love this one.
Watch.
I'm going to do a triple
subscript.
Lambda of copper K alpha.
Isn't that cool?
Lambda of copper K alpha is
equal to 1.5418 angstroms. And
if you use Moseley's law, you
get 1.546 and the delta here
is 1/3 of 1%.
This man was a positive
genius.
He was heading pell-mell for
the Nobel Prize, but
he never got it.
Why not?
World War I broke out in 1914
and Moseley was passionately
concerned about World War I.
He wanted to fight.
He wanted to fight for the
Allied cause and he enlisted
in the Army.
Rutherford was furious.
Rutherford called the Minister
of War, which is analogous to
the Secretary of Defense and
said, give him a desk job.
Put him up in Oxford at
a military laboratory.
And Moseley said,
no, I refuse.
I'm going to fight.
And so he was sent
to Gallipoli.
Gallipoli, as you may know, was
one of the bloodiest sites
of World War I.
A quarter of a million Allied
troops and 1/3 sort of a
million Turkish troops were
killed at Gallipoli.
Almost 2/3 of a million
people died for that
little piece of land.
And on August 10th, 1915, at the
age of 27, Henry Moseley
was killed in the battle of
Suvla Bay, and they don't give
Nobel Prizes posthumously, and
so that was the way it ended.
There's a shot of Henry Moseley
with one of his books.
The tributes poured in from
all over the world.
The physics community was
devastated because they knew
all of this stuff.
This is the one that really, I
think, says it best. This was
written by Robert Milliken,
an American.
He's the one that gave us the
elementary charge of the
electron, from the University
of Chicago at the time.
This is what Milliken wrote--
wrote this to
Rutherford to read.
"In a research which is destined
to rank as one of the
dozen most brilliant in
conception, skillful in
execution, and illuminating in
results, a young man 26 years
old threw open the windows
through which we can glimpse
the subatomic world with a
definiteness and a certainty
never dreamed before.
Had the European War no other
result than the snuffing out
of this young life, that alone
would make it one of the most
hideous and most irreparable
crimes in history." That's
when American scientists
knew to write.
It's beautiful writing.
What a tribute.
OK.
So let's move on.
Now that we've got Moseley's
Law, we've straightened out
the Periodic Table.
So we keep moving.
And I say, well, I gave you the
drawing of the spectrum.
Remember the spectrum?
The spectrum was here.
You see it?
I'll put it up real
quick again.
This was the spectrum.
OK.
This is intensity and this is
wavelength and this is K alpha
and this is K beta and this is
L alpha and this is L beta.
These are the data coming
from the x-ray tube.
This happens to be a
molybdenum target.
Well, it doesn't quite look like
what I've drawn, does it?
It looks a little bit like
it, but not quite.
This is definitely there.
You can see some of these lines
so I'm going to call
this spectrum A and it looks
like spectrum A has been added
on top of something else.
I'm going to call the something
else spectrum B and
the spectrum B looks
like this.
And in New England--
this curve has a shape because
it's New England.
This is called whale-shaped.
I don't know what they call it
in the rest of the country,
but it even looks
like a whale.
So you can go on
a whale watch.
So it starts--
it's a sharp front, goes
straight up, hits the maximum
and then-- are you
ready for this?
It tails off, all right?
Whales have tails, yes.
So what's the difference here?
Well, the spectrum A, we already
observed is quantized,
whereas this one isn't.
This one's continuous.
It has continuous values up to
this minimum value or, if you
like, maximum value of energy,
minimum value of wavelengths.
So we got that.
It's not quantized.
And the other thing that's
interesting is--
spectrum A, we said, is a
function of the identity of
the target.
z of the target, whereas this
one, it's a function of the
plate voltage.
So you can see in the diagram
I've shown you, as the plate
voltage changes, we get a series
of enveloping curves.
So this is V1 and this is V2--
greater than V1.
So this whale-shaped
thing is somehow
related to plate voltage.
And then beyond a certain
critical value, can you see
when you're down here at 15 or
20,000 volts, all you got is
the whale-shaped curve?
But somewhere between 20 and
25,000 volts, you hit a
threshold and now you switch on
the characteristic lines.
So with low voltage, you don't
get the characteristic lines.
You only get the whale-shaped
curve.
And then beyond a certain
critical value of V, it's as
though all of a sudden
these lines appear.
Low voltage, no lines.
High voltage, you get the
characteristic lines.
And what can we do here?
Well, we can compute K alpha,
L alpha by Moseley's Law.
The continuous spectrum can't
do anything with that, with
one exception--
here.
So let's look inside and figure
out what's going on.
We have a proposal here of
what's going on inside that
target atom.
So I'm going to make--
this could be the molybdenum
target up there.
So these are molybdenum
atoms. And just as
in Moseley's figure--
so this is body centered
cubic--
I can look that up on
the Periodic Table.
I know this is BCC crystal
structure, molybdenum atom
sitting here.
This is the anode.
It's charged positive and way
up top, I get the cathode.
So the cathode is shooting off
ballistic electrons and they
go zooming across the gap and
crash into anode, but up until
now, we've just said the
anode is some material.
Now we're going to take one more
peel off the onion and
say that these are discrete
atoms. It's not continuous
molybdenum.
It's molybdenum atoms.
And what do we know the
molybdenum atom looks like?
It's got a dense nucleus where
all the positive charge
resides and then there's this
almost vacuum-like zone with
the negative charge.
So when the electron comes in,
this electron sees the
negative charge around
the molybdenum atom.
What happens?
It's deflected.
Maybe it comes in on a closer
angle and it's scattered
through a higher angle.
Maybe it comes in almost
in between and it
hardly moves at all.
Now can you see that when you
have a charged species that
changes direction, that's called
an acceleration, and an
acceleration gives rise to
an emission of radiation?
So because the angle
of deflection--
so this is low-angle deflection,
this is high-angle
deflection.
So low-angle deflection means
low energy emission.
High angle means high-energy
emission, and the result is
this continue spectrum that
I've shown you here.
So this is the result of
low-angle scattering of the
ballistic electrons.
This is the result of high-angle
scattering of the
ballistic electrons, and
somewhere in the middle here
is the dominant angle.
I can't calculate this curve
with one exception.
Imagine the electron comes from
the cathode, and with all
of its energy is dead on and
stops, gives up all of its
kinetic energy to a photon.
That's the maximum amount
of energy possible.
Let's look at that.
That's the case where an
electron comes in, stops dead
here and then emits
the photon.
Sp the kinetic energy
is translated
into the photon energy.
So we can do that one.
That's a straightforward
calculation.
So the energy of the
incident electron--
E of the incident electron is
equal to product of the charge
on the electron and
the plate voltage.
Well, the charge on the electron
is the elementary
charge and the plate voltage
is whatever it is, and I'm
going to equate that with the
energy of the emitted photon,
and that's equal to
hc over lambda.
So now I can cross multiply and
I can call this the lambda
of the shortest wavelength.
That's the shortest wavelength
on the whale-shaped curve.
So by algebra, you're going to
get the product of the plane
constant times the speed
of light divided by the
elementary charge times the
plate voltage, which turns out
to be 12,400 divided by plate
voltage where the wavelength's
given in angstroms.
Just try it.
If you put 10,000 volts, you're
going to get 1.24
angstroms, which is smack dab in
the middle of the x-region
of the spectrum, and this is
called the Duane-Hunt Law.
That's the only thing
we can compute in
the continuous spectrum.
So I can get this one.
Lambda shortest wavelength,
because shortest wavelength is
maximum energy.
Now there's a fancier name for
this whale-shaped curve, and
it's the scientific community's
term, and it's a
German word.
It's called bremsstrahlung.
I love it.
You need to know this.
You can impress your
friends at parties.
What does bremsstrahlung mean?
Brems is the German word for
brake, as when you put on the
brakes of a car.
And strahl, strahl is
the word for ray.
And ung is like ing.
So this is raying radiation
and this is the
radiation of braking.
So the electrons are coming in
and when they come up against
the negative charge of the outer
shell the target atom,
they are slamming on the
brakes and skidding
everywhere.
So this is what bremsstrahlung
means: braking radiation.
So we're going to call--
I'm going to put a B here--
see that?
I was thinking ahead.
B is bremsstrahlung.
OK.
So we've got a lot going
here. for us.
I think we've explained
a fair bit.
Now I want to talk about
modern x-ray tubes.
What do modern x-ray tubes have
that these primitive ones
that Moseley worked
with and Roentgen
worked with didn't have?
So I want to show you that the
modern x-ray tube is the
result of improvements
made by an MIT alum.
His name was William Coolidge,
and he's the class of '96--
1896.
And he made a number
of improvements.
He actually taught for awhile
then eventually spent a good
part of his professional career
working as a research
scientist at the General
Electric Labs out in
Schenectady.
If you go down to the lobby of
Building 6, on the south side
of the lobby, there's
a showcase.
Look inside the showcase.
You'll see there's a little
display in honor of Coolidge.
So what's the first thing
Coolidge did?
He was an engineer so he was
thinking about making things
more efficient.
First thing he did is he turned
the discharge tube into
a vacuum tube.
Remember, Roentgen worked at
low pressure, but there was
still gas, and he was blinded
by the light and so on.
This means you don't get any
visible light, and secondly,
it's more efficient because if
you've got the tube like this
with the two electrodes, the
feedthroughs and you've got
gas inside, some of the
electrons are crashing into
the gas molecules,
and we don't care
about the gas molecules.
We want to get the electrons
crashing into the target.
So by going to vacuum, this
improves the efficiency.
No glow in the visible and
higher energy efficiency.
More x-rays out per
unit power put in.
What's the second
thing he did?
Second think he did
was hot cathode.
Remember, you're trying to rip
the electrons out of the
cathode and send them
on their journey.
So Coolidge reasoned that if you
heated the cathode, you'd
weaken the bonds, and the
electrons would come off.
They'd boil off much
more readily, OK?
Raise temperature to reduce bond
energy, to reduce binding
energy of the electrons.
The electrons in the cathode
makes them easier to boil off.
Think I've got a cartoon
of that.
Yeah, here it is.
So here's the tube lying
on its side.
So the cathode is over
here to the left.
It's negative.
Here's the anode to the right.
That's this purple thing here
and the electrons are moving
from left to right
and so he's got--
see, you can have multiple
electrical signals going
through the same conductor.
It's not the same.
You can't have an AC
waveform and a DC
waveform in the same conductor.
So you've got a big DC voltage
between the cathode and the
anode and you'd got a separate
little circuit going through
the cathode, running almost
like a toaster to
make it super hot.
So the potential between here
and here is 35,000 volts.
The potential along this stretch
of real estate might
be several hundred volts,
and furthermore, this
could be an AC signal.
It's Coolidge.
He was smart.
So this makes this hot and now
for per given voltage, you get
much more yield of
the electrons.
So that was pretty good.
I like that.
Smart.
Third thing he did was he heated
the cathode and he
cooled the anode.
Water-cooled anode.
Why?
You got to dissipate the heat.
All these electrons crashing
into the anode.
You raise the temperature of
that anode so high you'll melt
it and so they had to run the
tubes intermittently.
They just get a decent signal.
You have to take these x-ray
measurements over a long
period of time because the
amount of x-rays you get is
small, but you have to keep
shutting the thing down.
Otherwise, you melt
through the anode.
So he put that on a water-cooled
copper hearth and
was able to run continuous.
Continuous operation.
No more pulse current.
But sometimes when nature
hands you a
lemon, you make lemonade.
So I'm going to turn
this thing around.
I'll say, hey, wait a minute.
I don't want any water-cooled
copper anode.
Suppose I want to weld
some titanium.
Titanium melts at 1675 degrees
Centigrade and it's got a
voracious appetite for oxygen.
Well, this thing's
a vacuum tube.
So what if I were to take my
part and I put the two pieces
of titanium in the path of an
electron beam and I don't cool
the titanium?
Eventually, I get the
temperature so high that I can
weld titanium.
This is the birth of electron
beam welding.
And that's how you weld
refracting metals.
You get one of those titanium
bicycle frames
that cost about $4,000.
It might be tungsten
inert gas.
It might be electron
beam, depending.
So that's the flip side
of the technology.
By the way, if you were in
attendance observing
electronic beam welding, what
do you think is being
generated in the electron
beam welding apparatus?
X-rays, by the boatload
So there's a fourth thing--
maybe the most important thing
that Coolidge came up
with-- shielding.
You see the yellow here?
That's lead shielding.
Why did he choose lead?
Well, it's got a very high z.
That means it's got many
energy levels.
So that if you start looking at
the energy level diagram of
lead, you've got lots of
action up in here.
So what can happen?
When the x-rays come with their
high energy, the x-rays
from the tube on their way out
to get you, and everybody
standing observing
this marvel.
They excite electrons inside.
So these x-rays are absorbed.
The electrons inside the lead
rise, cascade down and now
they come out.
And what's the difference
in energy between
the x-ray and these?
The ones up here are
much lower energy.
So this is, if you like,
a frequency shifter
or an energy shifter.
So now we're using
photons to excite
electrons to generate photons.
And that's how the
shielding works.
So you want to absorb
and re-emit.
And while we're on the topic, he
gave us lead shielding and
he gave us beryllium windows
because they were using
silicate glass, just as you
use in your home, but the
silicate glass was absorbing
some of the x-rays.
So to get higher efficiency,
he chose beryllium.
Why did he choose beryllium?
Well, it's got a low z.
So that means it has
few energy levels.
So therefore, there's less
absorption and re-emission--
again, higher efficiency.
I think this was taken from
one of the other readings.
So they flipped it around.
See, here you can see the
cathode here, the anode.
That's one of these things.
All right.
So the window is up here.
You don't use lithium because
lithium is unstable in the air
unless you had a giant room of
humidity set at a dew point of
minus 38 degrees, see,
and then you can
use a lithium window.
Otherwise, you use beryllium
and lead down here.
Why'd he choose lead?
Well, you're pretty much at the
bottom of the naturally
occurring elements in
the Periodic Table.
So it's the cheapest of
all of these heavies.
All right.
So now let's take a few minutes
and talk about the use
of x-rays in characterizing
art.
So this painting here at once
time was arguably one of the
most recognizable paintings
in the western world.
It's The Angelus by
Jean-Francois Millet.
It was painted at 1857 to 1859
on commission for an insurance
company here in Boston.
The Boston Brahmins loved BA's
paintings of rural life in
19th century France.
And this is couple of peasants
who are giving thanks to God.
The Angelus is a prayer, and
they're thanking God for this
pitiful bounty of potatoes
evident.
Salvador Dali, as an art
student, was required to paint
this as part of training.
You know how when you learn to
play the piano, you reproduce
the works of the
Grand Masters.
So when you go to art school,
you have to paint.
He hated this painting.
For many years, it was here
in Boston, and then it was
repatriated around World War I,
it hung in the Louvre, and
then ultimately, now it's
in the Musee d'Orsay.
In 1963 when Dali was at the
peak of his career, he asked
the curator of the Louvre
if she would have
this painting x-rayed.
He said this painting
spooks him.
He doesn't like this painting.
And they x-rayed the painting.
What did they find?
They found that it had been
painted over down here.
Wasn't an art forgery, Millet
himself had painted it over.
You may have heard two years ago
there was this art find.
It was a van Gogh painting.
They found that van Gogh had
painted over one of his own
paintings that had never been
seen before even though the
pencil sketches survived, so
they assumed that maybe the
painting was destroyed
in World War II
or some such thing.
It turns out that van Gogh was
so poor at one point that he
valued the canvas over the art,
and he took his previous
painting, and he painted
over it.
OK.
So this was going on here.
This is the truth.
Now my speculation begins.
So what was underneath
here initially?
It was the casket of a baby.
Look at the pose.
These people don't look like
they're happy with their
bounty of harvest.
They're grieving.
This was this futility
of peasant life.
It was a hard life and
they lost their baby.
So imagine Millet paints this,
puts it on a boat, it comes
over to Boston, they unveil it,
and the directors of the
insurance company go, we can't
hang this in the lobby of an
insurance company.
That's my speculation.
It didn't take him three years
to paint this thing.
I think it spent most of
its time on the boat.
They sent it back
and said fix it.
So he put the basket
of potatoes.
That's my theory.
All right, look at the pose.
This is from the Galleria
Borghese in Rome.
I was there about two years
ago and saw this and went,
wow, referential.
You see, everything's
been said.
All of art has been said.
Now we're just recasting it.
So now here's Dali's revenge.
Now this is what he paints.
You see the man is shorter
than the woman.
His hat is down a little bit
below the waistline.
There's all sorts of
psychosexual things going on
here, but we're running
out of time.
So here's Dali and his father
and his dad is saying, see,
this is life, et cetera,
et cetera.
So you can see the reference.
See, man taller here, woman
taller, et cetera, et cetera.
Have you seen this one?
The Hallucinogenic Toreador.
OK, he went outside one day in
Manhattan to buy some pencils.
There was a company called the
Venus Pencil Company, you see.
And so he came back and made
this trompe l'oeil.
So this is the toreador.
Do you see the breast
here is the nose?
There is the face.
There are the flies of the
Thames and here is
the cape and so on.
Symmetry plane-- all of those
Venuses facing back, these
Venuses facing forward.
There's the bull.
The life force of the
bull is a crystal.
What is the crystal structure?
It's one of the 14
Bravais lattices.
If you ignore color, it's
simple cubic, isn't it?
And if you don't believe
me, check.
And if you don't appreciate
it, study.
Here's the symmetry plane.
Atoms, atoms, fly, fly
et cetera, et cetera.
What else do we have here?
Oh, this is the one he painted
on the occasion of the
revelation of the structure
of DNA.
It's hard to see, but
over here is the
double helix of DNA.
This is his wife Gaia and here
are people standing in cubic
arrays with guns pointing
at each other.
And the point that he's making
is that now that we've
discovered the instruction set
for reproduction of life, not
just human life, but life, we
are still at a point where we
can't resist killing
each other.
So this was the point and he
chose to use cubic arrays, and
I would venture to say
this is simple cubic.
If you put a fifth person here,
it would be-- are you
ready for this?
Body-centered cubic.
Oh, yes!
And there's more, but I think
we're running out of time so I
think at this point we will
dismiss the class.